the one thing that white liberals most
hate
is a black man who doesn't owe them a
favor
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster
i'm constantine kissinger and this is a
show for you if you want honest
conversations
with fascinating people what a terrific
guest we have for you today he's the
former chairman of the equalities and
human rights commission
trevor phillips welcome to trigonometry
thank you very much indeed francis and
constantine it's
it's been a while getting here but um
i'm glad we are here now
uh as are we uh as are we you know in
doing the research one of the things was
that shocked me the most is your age you
look so
unbelievably young it's unreal uh but
you you've had a distinguished career i
like this show already i love this show
already can we just could we just repeat
that bit for another
oh 25 times we can keep going on on that
topic but you've had a distinguished
career and the question i really want to
ask you is
how have you gone from being one of the
most prominent anti-racist
activists and spokespeople to being
where you are now which is
being one of the most prominent critics
of identity politics
suspended from the labour party and here
talking to us on this very problematic
show how has that happened
the world changed constantine the world
changed
um i wouldn't say that you know i'm not
one of those
idiots who sits around and says uh i
stayed the same
and everybody else changed that's
nonsense and that's
both arrogant and also the mark of
somebody extremely
dim but it is also true to say that
when i started on my journey in public
life
which was as a journalist really um the
things that mattered most
were what's true what do you know
what can you actually assert as opposed
to
what do you believe to a place
where actually now i think what seems to
be more important
is the last one what do you believe and
therefore what
facts quote unquote will you select and
whose gang do you belong to
um and i think uh if i were to give an
answer to your question that made
any sense i i suspect part of the
problem
um in if you like my public image as
you've described it
is that um i don't really belong to a
gang
so it's possible for anybody to say oh
he thinks this he thinks that
but uh and he's wrong mainly because he
doesn't belong to our
uh intellectual or political gang
well you know that's life i i i was
brought up to believe
that you stand on what you
what you think you say what you think
you argued out
publicly and you don't um you know
as we say in football you don't play the
man you play the ball
um i think we've now got to a place
where most political and most public
argument
is about playing the man or woman and
not being too interested in what it is
they
actually have to say so i suspect the
straight answer to your question is
that the way in which we talk about
things in public and the way
in which we deal with other people in
public
has changed um all of our ideas have
changed because the world has changed
but the way we argue things out have
changed so whereas in i guess 1980
people would have worried about what is
trevor phillips saying what they're now
talking about is
you know how many kinds of bastard is
trevor phillips really
[Laughter]
well let's explore that that very
subject on this show trevor
but you know your use of the word gang
is so
fascinating to me because i almost feel
like
the the sort of brutal enforcement of
conformity that happens within a gang
is kind of like one of the changes we've
seen in politics as well so
you know i i remember growing up in this
country watching
you know ken clark be in the
conservative party and dennis
skinner being in tony blair's labour
party and that was sort of the norm like
somebody who's completely
on many issues opposed to the leadership
of their party being prominent
being respected you know having their
voice heard to where we are now where
you have to toe the party line is that a
big change that is that has occurred
in in our lifetimes it's a huge change
it's poisonous
um you refer to my position within
or outside i'm a bit at the moment i'm a
bit shredding this cat
um i've been suspended by the late party
but not expelled
um and uh for the record since i wrote
to the labour party
now all 11 months ago explaining
or asking why i've been suspended i
haven't had a single communication
not a text not a phone call not a letter
you know you never write
here anyway um so i literally
um somewhere in some kind of limbo but
the whole
issue for me um and of me
has not really been an argument about
whether
i wrote something or said something was
right or wrong
the whole the reason that i was
suspended was because
my very presence is in some way
regarded as polluting the party now
that comes to your point that we no
longer seem to
be able to debate different points of
view
within a political party you either
belong
to the leadership faction or some other
faction
and depending where you are you are
fair game you are going to be attacked
by the
others not because of what you believe
or what you say you believe
but because you don't belong now
i i personally i mean that's gangster
politics
that's gangster politics and i'm not
having it
and trevor when did this culture begin
to seep into the labour party but also
modern day politics as well
that's a good and a very difficult
question to which i'm not sure i
entirely know the answer i think there
are a number of
um points at which you could
name it first of all i think that
the blairite group of which everybody
knows i was apart
introduced the idea into british
politics
that you could have message discipline
that is to say that if you belong to a
political party
and it takes a view then you have to be
pretty um fundamentally opposed to that
point of view
to go about saying that i think that the
party is wrong
that is to say that there was some
responsibility on you as a party member
as part of the
organization to stick to the line really
unless you really really had some very
basic
fundamental disagreement um and i think
that frankly was a good thing and it was
a good thing for democracy
because it meant that the citizen
understands what
the labour party or the conservative
party stands for
what i think then happened was post tony
blair's
um leaving the leadership of the party
is that people interpreted
message discipline as a sort of
authoritarian
imposition not that you had to be
persuaded
or you had to believe uh in some way in
what the party was saying
it was that if you remember the party uh
it doesn't matter what you think
as long as you go along with what the
line is
then you're in i think part of the
problem was that labor itself
forgot to try to persuade people and
simply
started to tell people what to do and
then others copied it the tories copied
it when
cameron and osborne were in government i
think something else has happened though
since um then and this is in a way
i suppose pretty much fundamental to my
view of contemporary politics
in in when i was involved in student
politics and
in my early time in politics you could
always say
that in the if you think of car politics
as a vehicle as a car
that there were two people in the front
one
was economics and one was identity and
culture and historically
economics had its hand on the steering
wheel you know you decided
where you stood depending on whether you
were for a big state
whether you're for a lot of spending or
whether you're for you know uh
deregulation and so on
and the identity questions race gender
and so on
sort of went along behind that i think
over the last 10 to 12 years maybe since
the
um since the financial crash
something has happened in which the
position has been inverted
and now identity has its hands on the
steering wheel
and that's a problem because it's no
longer
your position in politics isn't just
isn't just determined by what you think
let's say about race or about trans
right it's also
influenced by what you are and what you
look like
so people who happen to be female
have greater authority on issues to do
with gender
people who look like me apparently have
greater authority in the issues of race
well this is all a bit bizarre isn't it
because the fact that i am black doesn't
make me
much of an authority just on on race or
racial equality why would it
i mean the fact that i've got a liver
doesn't turn me into
a a surgeon the question i think
something's happened in politics
in which the virtue and the value of
knowing stuff of having an argument an
argument
that you can sustain has uh
has sort of disappeared in
um and been subsumed under the
prevalence of for example
the the jargon phrase now is lived
experience
if you can say i've got this lived
experience it gives you
some automatic authority when frankly
as i say you know because somebody
happens to have a brain
frankly i'm not letting them take a
scalpel to my head
you know you need to know stuff but
trevor
let me just push back on that idea so
wouldn't you say that
your experience of uh racism and your
opinion of racism is going to be more
valid than mine
because you're a black guy and you grew
and you were around in the 80s and the
70s
and you saw a real visceral visceral
hatred to black people
that as a white person i've never
experienced
no why why would it
no i mean the point is look
i've experienced those things um
but there are two there are two issues
here
first of all the fact that i experienced
um you know going on on leading
demonstrations against the national
front in the 70s
doesn't say anything about my knowledge
and ability
to deal with the ethnic pay gap
in a large corporation there is
absolutely no
particular relationship between those
two things
and the question you having to have ask
yourself is
does which one of those things matters
more today
the national front doesn't exist
we put the british national party out of
business
but what we do know is that um
some ethnic groups are about 50 percent
behind
others in in
average pay which one of those things is
most important right now
well i would say it's a second it's a
pay question and the fact that i might
have marched
against the national front doesn't
automatically give me any authority
on that second question it happens that
i know
quite a lot about it probably more than
most but that's because
i spend a lot of time studying charts
i've done
a lot of the research i've you know i
have a couple of companies uh one is a
big recruitment company one is a smaller
data analytics company which
sort of started as a hobby but is now a
commercial enterprise
and we work with a lot of clients so we
know stuff and it doesn't matter
the fact i've got the skin the color
i've got
isn't what gives me authority and
knowledge there it's the fact that i
spend
night after night after night trying to
solve the problems of our clients
on these issues so this whole idea
that being a thing gives you automatic
uh authority over everything to do with
that thing is just nonsense and by the
way
the other point is the fact that i might
have had an experience as a black person
doesn't mean every other black person's
had the same experience that's the thing
i hate most
the idea that once i've walked into a
room everybody thinks that they know
exactly everything about me
and that every other black person is
exactly the same
now yeah if you want to put the r word
on anybody
uh or any kind of thinking that's it
um troy you're giving me goosebumps here
because
it's such a refreshing take and it's
refreshing while simultaneously being
i feel like the way we used to talk and
think about these things the facts
matter
feelings less so yeah you can add a
little bit of experience here or there
to modify
your view on things but overall what
matters is is
is our ability to look at reality so how
do we
untangle this web that we've woven for
ourselves where
uh what who you are matters a lot more
than what what you actually
know and and just this everything is
determined by your skin color like it's
regressive
beyond belief to me how do we get out of
that
you got to fight every battle every day
i mean you know
to take um a sort of apparently
not very related example but it's it's a
you're asking about how do you win um an
identity battle
probably the biggest
yeah well let me let me just take what
might appear to be a little bit of a
diversion but it's not very big one
the biggest single identity question in
the united kingdom today
is probably the issue of britishness as
opposed to the components of britishness
and the political area in which that
being fought out is
over scottish independence now our
friends in the scottish national party
will say that their nationalism is all
civic and it's all based on policy
and all that but actually they know
and everybody else knows that for 25
years
they have fought little battles
every day in every school in every
workplace
to have the idea of scottish identity
and ethnic identity
recognized essentially tartanizing
scottish life
now i'm not criticizing them for that
but in a sense i admire what they've
done
because they have simply fought every
battle to assert that scottishness
is significant as a significant identity
and should be part of people's
decision-making about politics about
where they work
how they treat their neighbors and so on
and
in the same way i think the answer to
your question
is there isn't a sort of great big
single answer
i think this is an issue that was going
to be fought on every single
front on the issues of let's say statues
on the issues of what's in the
curriculum on the question of
should you monitor ethnicity pay gaps or
not
and at the heart of it for me i mean you
know i'm a geek
basically what i should have said right
from very beginning is
what you need to understand is i'm a guy
who is happiest
not doing this but worrying about
spreadsheets
running software to try to work out what
the patterns are
where is the problem and therefore where
do we put the effort
so my big thing to be honest is i i
think we need more data we need more
facts and we need to share that
more with the public at the moment when
we talk about race
it's all about feelings it's all about
my impression
even though the impression of an
individual doesn't tell you very much
about the whole group or indeed the
whole
country so when we talk about race and
identity
it's like um i suppose i would sometimes
make
is that trying to read the the political
landscape
um with an impressionist painting
rather than when what you really need is
a google map
that is clear and sharp
and trevor don't you think part of the
problem is as well is that we ingest
narratives we all have narratives
whatever they may be you know
everyone who voted brexit is racist the
eu is a universal force for good
scottish nationalism is positive english
nationalism is negative
and like you said we don't appear to be
analyzing the data
why have we become so obsessed with
narratives and not thinking for
ourselves
because it's way easier it's way easier
i mean the point about most politics um
is a very simple one there is no good
or bad in any political decision
otherwise it wouldn't be a decision
i mean you know what idiot would say
there's a good way to
to tackle the health pro health service
or covid
or the economy and there's a bad way why
do we choose a bad way man
i mean that's that's that i mean that's
just
stupid the point is most political
decisions
are only political decisions because
what you're actually doing
most of the time is choosing between bad
and worse
and the way that you evaluate bad or
worse
to some extent depends on your character
it depends on
the the range of knowledge and data that
you have available
and it depends by and large on your
instinct i mean
you know i've been i've run big
organizations i've been in politics a
lot
not a long time one of the things that
um i think most politicians
hesitate to say is
that almost every decision you take has
to be taken
on the basis of incomplete information
you know it's always great and we've
seen this a lot in covid
that everybody knows six months down the
line
exactly what should have been done the
truth is when you have to take the
decision
almost always you're having to take it
on the basis
of some data that you have available
but a guess or a projection on what
might
happen and to some extent that will
depend on
your experience there's a i won't get
into the boring tech
technicalities of it but there's a sort
of um a kind of analysis called bayesian
analysis which
in which you use your experience of
situations
to try to predict what's going to happen
next and some of it
frankly just depends on what your
instinct and your preference is for the
kind of society
you want to live in are so for example
somebody like me
who really values individual
choice more i think
than what you might call solidarity
which doesn't make me a tory it just
means
that i've grown up in a circumstance in
which
frankly i don't really like to be told
what to do
by the state because that's mostly run
by people who are not like me
so my tendency generally speaking is to
go
yeah okay thanks very much i'll make my
own decision i'm not going to depend on
you
somebody else might equally validly
who for example has um
spent their life and benefited from the
health service or the education system
say i trust government i trust the state
that doesn't make them bad but it means
they'll make a different decision to me
now i think part of the problem with
politics at the moment is that it just
refuses to recognize that both
of those positions can be equally valid
and the task of politics is to navigate
and negotiate between
those different views i mean
it's a really really
you know really good way of summing it
up because
it just seems at the moment that
those two types of people they can't
agree on anything
they can't agree whereas before we used
to listen and go well look i don't agree
with what you said but i can see the
merits and the value of your argument
but now it just seems that we are two
ships who are just simply drifting
further and further apart
you're just talking about me well
yeah well i know i know the two of you
basically after this you're just gonna
punch each other in the face
so i know that i i know how you lot have
fun so
yeah but let's
[Laughter]
have the rosters around in in a minute
but um
i think you're right up to a point but
um
one of the things i when i was um an
editor and the executive producer
one of the uh terms that i basically
banned was
something you just said we are like this
or we are like that and it's interesting
see i think that's now used very very
widely what people usually mean by that
actually is everybody i know is like
that
they don't actually know the whole
country is like that
they don't know that all men are like
they just know that everybody they talk
to
is like that i think this is part of the
problem
you've discussed on this show i know the
echo chambers
that's been encouraged by social media
and so on and i think that there's a big
problem in this country and to some
extent in the united states
that the we that the decision makers the
opinion mongers
uh that you know the what vernon
bogdanov the constitutional historian
calls the exam passing classes
when we when people like us use the term
we
we actually literally mean people like
us but unfortunately that's only 15 10
15
of the population i think the truth is
that 80 of the population don't have
those kind of
knock-down drag out you're this you're a
fascist
no you're a kind of anarchist lunatic
argument most people in most of the time
in most families
they might disagree about brexit or you
know
or about whether we should have masks or
not have masks
but they will listen to each other with
respect
and in the end they'll say look look
uncle jim
i hear what you're saying but i just i'm
just not convinced most of this country
i think doesn't participate in that sort
of vicious
rhetoric and i think for myself that is
the biggest problem in politics
but the people who are having most of
the air time
who get most of the space who get on
shows like this
are busy shouting each other down
and telling everybody else he's a wanker
excuse me forgive me i know you don't
like this
you can swear all you want to go for it
he he's a tosser uh he doesn't know his
arse from his elbow whereas most people
go
yeah the yeah okay but
most things are a matter of judgment
they're not
black and white right or wrong and we've
simply
that the elite classes one reason i hate
the
the political and media elite with a
deep loathing
they have simply lost the skill or the
desire
to have that kind of conversation yeah i
mean
it's an interesting point you make we we
do try and steer away from that as much
as we can on the show
uh but obviously you're gonna get people
uh coming through as well who have
strong opinions about stuff and it's a
balance to be struck
uh in our defense
so to interrupt you i have very strong
opinions as as
my my children would say i i will start
not that i could but i will start an
argument in an empty room
but that does but but what i
what i object to about what we're doing
at the moment
is that not only do we disagree but we
disrespect people with whom we disre
disagree and i think that's intolerable
i think that is the antithesis of a
democratic society
i think you're right and uh we we all i
think particularly with social media all
of us can take responsibility i
certainly would include myself in this
for sometimes as you say playing the man
and not the ball
uh so i take i take your criticism
gratefully
but but one thing we will say is the
episode will be called trevor phillips
called me a wanker
that would be brilliant francis
how is your cyber security i've got a
virus from an unnamed website of course
you do
you're not alone francis during the
pandemic british online infrastructure
has faced an astronomical rise
in targeted cyber attacks which is what
i'm sure happened to you
that is dreadful what can i do to defend
myself
that is where pockets seem come in they
offer businesses like ours
a special solution that alerts us to
hackers crackers
and malicious employees like anton not
only that
they are the only seam provider to offer
pay
as you go cyber defense for companies
they're british based
absolutely and they're from doncaster so
they need the work
i mean you say that actually they have
kept their prices flat during the
pandemic to make sure companies can get
the protection they need
pocket seem are offering trigonometry
fans a 10
discount all you got to do is hit them
up by email at
info at pocketseem.co.uk and
make sure the subject of that email is
trigonometry and they will give you your
10
discount for managed cybersecurity that
email again
is i n f o p
o c k e t s i
e m dot co dot u k and don't forget to
have trigonometry in your subject line
so you get your 10 discount can i just
say if you need
that spell you really shouldn't be
running a business
well listen trevor i want to talk to you
about identity we started with it and
you alluded somewhat to it
uh this idea and you get we we have
mentioned it but i want to go deeper
into
this idea that you should see yourself
as part of a racial group as a tribe as
a member of a tribe
and i should see myself as a member of a
different tribe
and francis should see himself as a
member of another tribe
where does that lead us because you know
i've studied
a little bit of history and i i'm not
optimistic where what does that take a
society
in your opinion
well it could take you into
rwanda or some of the worst excesses
that we've seen in the united states
but it could equally take you i think in
a
modern society into a different place i
mean
you know tribalism we think of as
automatically a bad thing because
it has often descended into a
competition
for resources between people who look
like me
are related to me and people who look
like you
and are related to you and i don't have
to make any judgment about what you
think what sort of person you are what
your desires are what your ambitions
are as long as you look like you look
you're the enemy i i get that
i get that that is one outcome
of tribalism but
maybe this is in a way coming back to
what i was saying earlier on
about the influence of background i i
come from a very big family you know i'm
i'm the 10th
of as far as we know 10
of my father's children and um
you know to tonight for example we're
we're going to be on the zoom
and there'll probably be 40 50 of us
and that's just a bit that's just a bit
of the outfit but we are
we are a tribe but in that tribe there
are
doctors there are lawyers there are
management consultants there are people
you know there are people who um act as
bailiffs there are people who are
unemployed um there are people who
do not go out to work there's i think
there's probably a millionaire or two in
there somewhere
um there are all sorts but there's
something that
brings us together we all have in this
case the same
grandmother and there are things that we
share because of that
there are lots of other things we don't
share because about that
but i value the things that we share
i mean they are important to me they're
the things that make me the sort of
person i am
to a large extent that doesn't mean
that where i to you know come on a
similar gathering in
um the kitchen family or the foster
family
i would think i'd automatically think
let's eliminate the kissings let's
eliminate the fosters because they're
not as good as us
what i'd probably be doing is thinking
what those guys got that we could copy
so my view about this idea of identity
is that we should never get into the
place where
what we're saying is identity is bad
because we are all the same under skin
which is complete
balls everybody knows that we are not
yeah we are creatures of our environment
we are people who belong who belong you
know i'm
i come from a a religious background
christian
background i believe in it and that
it's important to me it gives me my
values that doesn't mean that i think
somebody who has a different
faith is a worse person actually
for example there are many things from
islam i wish we could borrow
for example attitude to alcohol so my
point about this whole issue of identity
is there is nothing wrong
with cleaving to an identity regarding
it as important
what is wrong is regarding everybody
else's identity
as somehow lesser than yours
or wrong and secondly
thinking that everybody who shares some
aspect of your identity
has to be exactly the same as you and
take the same outlook as you
as you do that's where we're going wrong
with that issue
well let me add another point uh to to
borrow your family metaphor the one
thing that
will unite uh your family is
some sort of shared values which which
while not explicit
will be there right they are things
perhaps passed down by your grandma
grandmother to everybody else and i
wonder
whether that is where we are going wrong
because you you mentioned the issue of
britishness before
i can certainly tell you from my point
as a first generation immigrant
you know i i am surprised by
how terrified people are even admitting
that such a thing as british identity
exists we can't seem to define
what british values are and again when i
say we i do mean that the chattering
classes of course i do
um so there is that that perhaps is an
issue
do we have enough holding us together uh
when
when we're encouraged to focus a lot on
our individual identities do we have
enough as a society to hold us together
i absolutely think we do and by the way
i mean
let's take this issue of him of um first
generation immigrants
you know if you and this is where
you know i'm a data guy so i i don't
worry about what somebody told me in
tesco last week i go and look at the
data
so if you ask people in this country in
general
do you think speaking english
routinely is going to be an advantage
to your children 80-something percent
probably more will say yes and the
people who are
most hawkish on this issue are not white
people
who tend to go oh yeah well we need to
we need to take into account the fact
that all those pakistanis speak some
other funny language at home and no no
no actually the people who are mo
talkish are the first
are the immigrants why because our
experience is
if you are going to prosper in this
society
which in many ways is hostile you
absolutely need to master
this society's ways starting with its
language
so immigrant parents and i i i defy you
to tell me that this is wrong
immigrant parents of all backgrounds
will be saying to their children
you have to be twice as good as them to
get half as far
so pass your exams don't give me any
nonsense about you're going to be a
musician
or an actor or any of that kind of stuff
go and become an accountant or a doctor
or a lawyer get a job
and then you can play as much music as
you like once you've got the job
right that is the immigrant position
immigrants more than anybody else
actually
cleave to the idea the reality of what
being british is like
that's why they come here so this whole
idea
this is somehow you know we've got to um
get all complicated and get ourselves in
a state about british identity
because otherwise the immigrants are
going to feel a bit alienated
only comes from people who have never
met an immigrant
actually agreed yeah agree but that's
exactly my point though trevor which is
it's the the people who are the
chattering classes
who don't understand the impact of their
actions
on people like me and my children who
are going to be telling them
that they don't need to you know
whatever it might be whether it's to
speak english or to
to understand the local culture they
don't need to blend in or settle in or
they don't need to integrate they need
to just
you know dive as deeply as they can into
the russian jewish identity or whatever
other nonsense they come up with should
i tell you why
should i tell you why and this is one of
the reasons that this is one of the
reasons that all that lot
all that chattering class hate me um i i
i frequently say that
the one thing that white liberals most
hate is a black man
who doesn't owe them a favor
and who they can't patronize one of the
reasons is
they like the idea that you know
we are outsiders who suffer
who need to be looked after who
constantly need to be saved
it's really important that we stay
different
and that we stay at the bottom of the
pile because
if we don't two things are true
one is we don't need to depend on them
to look after us
and the other thing that is true is that
we might
actually take their jobs and of course
one of the problems that we are going to
see and which some extent seeing it
already
is that um some minority groups
particularly indians and chinese
are earning in those cases something
like 12
and uh 15 more on average per hour
than white brits now
i don't sit inside the homes of white
families
but i bet you i bet you that there is a
sneaking anxiety about
all of these clever indian doctors and
accountants
somehow creeping up the ladder we're
seeing it
in technicolor in the united states
where
whites are likely to become a minority
they're not that bothered to be honest
about african americans because they
you know they they can always patronize
african americans because
we're still or not we that african
americans are still way behind
they really hate the asian americans
really hate the asian americans
because actually those guys have pitched
up they're the fastest growing
population group and you know what they
dominate
some of the industries particularly some
of the new ones the digitals
so one of the issues i think that we are
all going to have to confront
is the sense that um
the the old order of things in which
you know elite white people sit at the
top
of society they look down
on us and can stroke our heads and tell
us how much they care about us
and that makes them happy because that
means everything stays the same
that they are unsettled particularly by
anybody from a minority
who says you know what don't really need
you to look after me mate
i can get on with it and you see that
many many times
particularly with first generation
immigrants who are openly conservative
or black people who are openly
conservative you just see white liberals
they can't seem to get their head around
it
like my mother is you know a
first-generation immigrant
uh you know right-wing voted brexit you
know latin american whatever else
and my liberal friends well actually i
don't have any
anymore but unfortunately i was gonna
say francis
who is that
[Laughter]
but when i had them they couldn't seem
to get their head around the fact that
that she would be in this particular
mold
they just couldn't believe it i mean
look
let us bear in mind that on average some
minority groups
are less well-off in relation to
employment
and education nobody i hope on this
conversation is going to deny
the existence of individual personal
bigotry
and the fact that there are some
cultural and what people
these days though they don't understand
what they mean by this
there are some structural inequities
which are which relate to race you know
none of that
there's no point in arguing about that
because trevor just
clarify that for us because i i think
it's an important point when you say
structural inequities and you say that a
lot of people don't know what they mean
by that
could you explain to people who are
open-minded watching this program who
who
keep having this idea of structural
inequality
shove down their throat by people who as
you say don't really understand what
they're talking about
what what is the legitimate case for
structural inequities in society
all right let me if i may a small
mini seminar on this um perfect
i was very lucky because i was very
lucky because i'm very old
i was very lucky to have met stokely
carmichael later known as kwame toure
who was one of the leaders
of the radical end of the civil rights
movement he was the leader of the
student on
coordinating um non-violent coordinating
committee
in the late 60s
and he would have described himself did
describe himself as a
scientific socialist a marxist
he and a man called charles hamilton
coined the phrase
institutional racism because they wanted
to make a distinction between
themselves and martin luther king
stokely's argument was that
you could have replaced the entire
new york police department with an
choir of black angels and it would still
be arresting and beating
black young people that
some of the symptoms of racial
discrimination
and uh bigotry were independent
of what anybody any individual what
thought and how good and how lovely they
were his argument was
that king and others spent all their
time trying to persuade
white people to be nice when actually
that would only have a marginal impact
on
uh where black people lived what jobs
they got their levels of education
and so on i as it happens agreed with
stokely carmichael and
still do spin forward to today
some of the so-called radicals who
frankly are not very radical at all
um shout about structural racism and
when you test them what they really mean
is
why don't we pull down some nasty people
whether they are
they happen to be dead white men who are
um
remembered in bronze or maybe somebody
who's made some unpleasant remark
and what they mean by structural racism
is some really
bad individual bigotry what i mean by
structural racism
is that for example when people of
pakistani muslim
background came here they almost
totally went to areas where
um industries with which they were
familiar textiles
were booming and that's why they were
brought in they were needed
to work in those industries what then
happened was
those industries died that meant that
the towns that they lived in
died somebody once said to me the point
about burnley
is that the only reason for it still to
exist is it's got is because
it's got a football club so the point
about that the problem for that group
is not that everybody hates them because
they're pakistani muslims
it is that structurally history put them
in a place
where they were at a disadvantage and
generation after generation
for reasons that will be obvious they
remain at a disadvantage
and that is there are exa there are
parallels in
all other groups by the way uh some
other groups
indians i refer to have had the reverse
experience
they have followed in the professional
part of some other groups
and actually their culture their
background their situation
to some extent has helped them to
prosper
so my point is that the people talk
about structural racism
and then put as a solution
let's get rid of person x or let's
cancel person y
literally don't know what they're
talking about they literally don't know
what they're talking about
they are pursuing an old school
conservative position that says if only
people would be lovely to us
then we would solve this race problem
actually they're not the real radicals
the real radicals are the people who say
we have to do something about history
and geography
and economics to solve this problem
trevor let me just difficult
ask one question one question to for a
better understanding of what you're
saying
so the only issue i have with what
you've just said is
if that structural difference has
disadvantaged pakistanis in your example
but advantaged indians
can we really call that racism isn't
that just structural difference due to
history and
economic inequality due to poverty
is it not inappropriate to describe that
as racism
probably if you use the word racism
to mean personal dislike but you see i
don't think of racism as personal
dislike i mean let me absolutely clear
one of the reasons i
that i suppose i really get on these
people's tits
is that i don't really care what white
people think about me
they care about it a lot these people
are obsessed
with being liked and they're steamed
by white people i literally do not care
what i care about is that i do not lose
opportunities which should be open to me
because a white person is prejudiced
against
me i don't want them to like me but i
want them to recognize me
for what i am so when we talk about
racism
one of the reasons i criticize all those
critical race theory
nut jobs is that they're not radical
at all they talk about racism like it's
a fashion statement
i think about it as a social
and economic and cultural uh
cage uh in which some from which some
people cannot escape
that to me is a serious conversation
this whole idea that
you know if we could get people to be
nicer
it's pathetic it's just pathetic it's
it's you know it's like the kid
at the back of the class who really
desperately wants the most popular
kid in the class to like him and be his
best mate i mean honestly
that's radicalism give me a break
hey francis where do you get your
computer accessories
from that shelf over there no you idiot
i mean where do you buy them
instead of buying from some faceless
multinational why not support a small
british business
we're taking back control of our mouse
max taskmat is a uk company that has an
incredible new product called the
taskmat scribble
it combines your mouse map with a
whiteboard so you can quickly
and easily create an update task list
make notes
or just scribble i like scribbling it's
great if you're like me
and struggle with to-do lists it's the
perfect tool for getting yourself
on track staying on top of your to-do
list and getting information
out of your head so you can focus on the
things that matter
i use taskmat to make sure i never miss
a meal
snack or nap true and by the way getting
your taskmat scribble couldn't be easier
not only is it available on amazon but
you also get 15
off if you use our promo code which is
of course trigger
15 that's trigger one five hit the link
in the description or search for
task max scribble on amazon and use the
promo code
trigger 15 and unleash a world of
productivity
and naps
and we were talking about the the
structure and equality but
when you were talking about that my my
pushback would be but that also applies
to
a lot of white working-class people as
well particularly communities like
in colombia or wales where i mean i
taught in cornwall
and we're not you know first time ever
went there it was holiday season and i
thought oh this is lovely
and then i went to teach her and i was
shocked at the levels of poverty
that these children were having to exist
in not live exist
correct i completely agree i mean one of
the things that um
is saddest about what has happened in
this country
you know it there's a great tradition
here of
um seaside towns um and when i was
growing up
you know holiday to south end or
um a day trip to somewhere
you know wimbledon endorses or somewhere
was a really
for an inner city kid this was
this is fantastic these were special
places
and i think same would be true in the
north harrogate or blackpool
one of the saddest things i think that
has happened over the last
20 to 25 years has been the absolute
collapse of many towns which depended
on a single industry in those cases
tourism
but the same is true say about coalfield
towns
or most of the steel towns and
um one of the things that i am most
interested in
i am really interested in is the fact
that
a lot of these towns steel shipping
um coastal uh resorts
have died um economically
and they have become quite sad places
we thought for a long time the way to
deal with this problem
was just about jobs and this was a labor
issue so we give peop
we try and find people new jobs and we
create industrial estates and so on
one of the things i think we have
completely missed
and this is coming back to your point
about white
britons is that alongside
being for example a coal miner
it wasn't just the job you might spend
six days underground
you know and there you were in the in
the heat
and you were knocking out coal and
everybody looked the same because
everybody looked black and so on but the
thing that actually made
your week was the fact that you were
secretary of the miner's welfare
that gave you status in that community
one of the things that's happened with
all of these towns what you might call
company towns
is all of that has been destroyed and we
can't replace that
by giving a man or a woman a job on a
sort of windswept industrialist state
where he or she is working next to
somebody
who doesn't live in the same village as
them they have to drive to work or take
the bus rather than walk
to the the work the factory or the steel
works
and so on and that problem
actually if you'd like to put it in
these terms
has become is structurally a white
problem it is a problem for
white britons who have that particular
history
and we should recognize it as such
because it's
not just a straightforward economic
problem remember what i said about
what's taken over in the identity taking
over
what has really struck most people
that's why people
in the so-called red wall i think have
defected from
labor is that the labour party failed to
recognize
what working people in this country lost
when those industries and those towns
changed
they didn't just lose jobs but they lost
identity so for example and i stopped
ranting about this in a second but i
can't tell you how strongly i feel about
it
because i've met a lot of these people
they are you know i have family
who um who live in the midlands
one of the things that you see
is a sadness of parents
who lived in the same village as their
own parents and worked in the same
factory or mill or whatever it is
whose parents worked in the same lived
in that village and worked in the same
factory so there's three or four
generations
and now suddenly these people
i know their children are nowhere near
them because they've had to move away
to have a job in a city somewhere if
they want to see their grandchildren
they have to get in the car and drive an
hour
whereas you know their own grandparents
could just walk around the corner i
think we haven't yet
grasped in this country the absolute
trauma that the
uh 80s and the 90s visited on
many parts of this country and that's
the problem
of the political and media elite who are
busy yapping
about you know the the the fact that
their children can't do it
exams this year and how terrible it is
when these people's whole history
and identity is crumbling in front of
their faces
sorry i'm i'm ranting on about i can't
tell you how strongly i feel about it
i'll be i'll be honest with you trevor
i'm really really glad that we talked
about this because
like i said i've worked in those types
of communities and it's something we
simply don't discuss we demonize
these people they're thick they're
stupid they voted brexit blah blah blah
and it's like
you don't understand what it's like when
everything that you value your entire
sense of community
has just been eroded over time and the
worst bit is
no one cares no one cares yeah because
we're all based all the
all the liberal elite are all based in
london and they don't address those
problems because quite simply they don't
concern them
but i think i would go even deeper than
what you
then what you say i think these people
have felt that their dignity has been
stolen from them
and i think that's where i believe anger
comes from
completely and i i i i will if you don't
mind i will tell you how i got to this
point
and it is partly the answer to
constantine's earlier question about
identity
and the commonality i i
really got to this point of thinking not
by looking first at white communities
but looking at
black communities in the united states i
was making a film
about the preacher al sharpton
and i went round some parts of the the
northeast with with him
i went to um see him preach
in a church in new jersey
and hundreds of people came to hear him
preach he's fantastic preachers he's
you know he's great performer so on so
forth
but the thing that most struck me and it
and it brought back my own childhood in
many ways
was that um black american churches
are very formal
they have a structure there is a
preacher there are
elders there are stewards and when
people come out to church
in black churches they've dressed in
their best
it's an important moment of the week
and i remember talking to a guy who was
actually the chief student in this
church
who i think most of the week is a
janitor
but on sunday he is the chief steward of
his church
hundreds of people defer to him you
don't get to sit down
unless he or his team sit you
down if you cause that if the children
need to go out to sunday school he's
organizing he
is numero uno and in that community
he's got identity he's got status
so he can afford to you know he doesn't
mind the rest of the week
that he's completely invisible to the
white people who go
in and out of the building that where
he's a janitor because on sunday
he's the guy and i
i i realized actually
that the clever people the exam passing
people
like us because our lives are fulfilled
we have status we are deferred to
you know people don't generally speaking
overlook
us on this point you're massively
overestimating us
[Laughter]
i'd like to find someone who defers to
me it hasn't happened yet oh there you
go
no no he doesn't yeah that will be the
opening of the interview trevor just a
black man bowing to me that will make me
look great
i i i just assume that you have a large
group of people who are not on camera
who are simply you know in between
coming in
and brushing your face and you know
rubbing your feet and all that i mean
what is wrong with it
but i i interrupted you i take your
point of course that
what you're really talking about i think
is the atomization of society the
destruction of community
uh and the fact that people no longer
have meaningful
opportunities for status outside of
being on television
being on the radio writing for
newspapers whatever else
but your word i think your word dignity
is more important than any of that
actually i think you you you hit it
right it's it's about
people's own dignity and i think
we haven't grasped th when i say we here
i am talking
about decision makers and opinion
formers
because we haven't lost any of that i
don't think we have grasped
how bigger loss it is
for millions of people in advanced
societies
yeah and it all goes back as well to
globalization this idea that you know
that we are
we are one you know that we are all
interconnected that
identity doesn't really matter because
you know we're all european and
and it seems that that liberal elite
just don't
seem to be learning the lessons they
don't learn the lesson of brexit
they didn't learn the lesson of trump
and now with biden elected they think
that that problem has gone away
when it all biden is is a stink skin
graft on a festering wound
nice nice i wish i thought
he's used that line before he did very
well
i i tell you um i i agree with that to
an extent i
tell you what i think is uh an issue
here
i i think a lot of us who um
are certainly in our 50s and 60s
who were the first to know in our
families to go to university lola all
that stuff
we and i'm hesitating because i
i never like to get into the amateur
psychology game but
i think a lot of us are people who
in a way got away from our family
background we escaped what we were i
mean for example in my case
pretty much everybody in my family um
you know my
great-great-grandmother was a slave that
all sorts of things
about my family which you know
are humiliating and awful and so on
um and pretty much everybody in my my
parents
my mother worked in a sweatshop my
father basically worked
in uniform railway man postman all that
most of his life and the expectation was
that we would all be in some kind of
uniform
actually either last i've never been in
uniform
i escaped all of that except when i was
in the salvation army
i've escaped all of that you know i and
i live a life
that wasn't just isn't just different
from my parents
it was unimaginable to my parents they
didn't even know people like me
existed if you said i mean um
so i think the problem is that people in
our class because we escaped our past
in a way tend to treat other people
who think their past is important and
are still embracing it so
you know they go around to their mum
around the corner and so on
and that is really important to them we
kind of think that's all a bit
um there's a bit quiet it's a bit
old-fashioned a bit backward
but actually that's what most people
want for their lives
and i i think your point about
globalization is important
but in a different way i think the
problem is that the deracinated
folks of our class basically think
people who aren't like us are
essentially a bit
backward when in fact i think we are the
ones who've
suffered loss um maybe i feel
differently about this
because i just started this conversation
by saying i come from a very big family
i love it to pieces you know a lot of
them think i'm a
you know disagree with me politically
and think why has he gone over to the
dark side
but they would never for one second
never for one second disrespect me
or hold me at a distance because
that thing that grandmother
great-grandmother
great-great-grandmother holds us
together and that's more important
than any difference we might have about
the way the world
works i think that the the big
losers at the moment actually are the
people who run things because they've
lost
that feeling and they they try to impose
their way of thinking which they say is
modern
you know the work thing on everybody
else
and everybody else is saying no
don't fancy it we can be perfectly
civilized and
like other people and you know we have
gay
brothers and sisters and nieces and sons
and daughters
that doesn't mean we've got to go all
kind of
mad about it in fact in a way
it's the people who are making a big
deal of this who are the mad ones
the people who say okay
sachin touch is gonna you know my niece
is gonna bring her wife around
and nobody blinks an eyelid that is what
equality looks like
not oh my god we've got to have
something that will make sure that d
feels comfortable what will make these
feel comfortable
is nobody talking about the fact that
dee's a lesbian
right right so i i get a
you know i'm really enjoying our
conversation i wish we had more time and
hopefully
when the lockdown is over we can get you
in the studio i'm ranting on
no uh on the contrary trevor i i just
wish we we could we could talk to you
uh for for much longer uh
i get a sense that you're quite
optimistic about the future
are you yeah
yeah i'm a believer and see well one of
them
i'm about to say something which i did
not start this interview
meaning to say and it's a tribute to
your skill as
interviewers because i've sat in your
seat
and not been able to do this but i'm
very optimistic i'm a great
i'm a believer in lots of different ways
um
i i was brought up in the church
uh i'm not about to give you a sermon
but i brought up in the church in the
the church
and one of the fundamental things about
being
our type of christian particularly i
suppose if you come from
our kind of background slavery
colonialism and so on
is that um faith is not some sort of
you know warm fuzzy blanket where you
hide from reality exactly it's exactly
the opposite
faith is entirely tied up with hope
um i was brought up believing that there
is a better world
and that actually part of our business
is to realize that better world as far
as we can
right here in this world
and that if you don't believe that
that there can be that better world what
possible incentive is there for you to
want to bother to make
things change well i'm a great believer
not only that it's your business it's
your duty
to try to create that better world but
that actually it's entirely possible
i mean that's that's what i've always
believed
um and i guess i will go to my grave
believing that
i don't it's one of the reasons that
when you know we're talking about race
i just absolutely don't buy this
nonsensical supposedly
um critical race theory idea that
all people of a particular color are
intrinsically evil
you can never get rid of racism you or
its effect rather
you can never do anything unless
i don't know you get rid of everybody
who you don't like
i think that's just that is the council
of despair
you know might as well just go slash and
slash your wrist mate i i'm
[Music]
the i always argue with my labour party
friends
why are you a socialist if you don't
believe in
in something in the possibility of a
better future
why are you a socialist i mean why are
you bothering why just
stay at home you've got to believe that
it is possible
for things to change otherwise
why bother to try to do anything about
where we are
sermon over no it's look
uh trevor it's been an absolute honor
having you on as i say i hope we can get
you back once the lockdown's over
because there's so much more we could
talk about but we are out of time we are
our time it's been a genuine pleasure
and
i i know that both i francis and i but
also a lot of our audience will
appreciate
the balanced and sensible view you have
on many of these issues i really i
really fundamentally believe that
but we've got one more question before
we let you go which is
what is the one thing we're not talking
about but we really should be
yeah well you know i um i i write for
the time i mean you know my my day job
is i run some businesses and
that's really great fun and and i'm
trying to get people to
apply science to politics so maybe you
know if i were a serious person
i'd give you a lecture about all that
but actually
the things and i you know i know i have
this reputation for being
supposedly controversial i think that's
all nonsense i'm sure i've said
something that somebody will regard as
controversial
but the things that really matter here
is the thing
i've written about in the last year
which i think is the most controversial
thing
which nobody seems to want to talk about
was miles davis a better trumpeter than
wynton marsalis
now this is the thing that people
could and should get into a fight about
because that's a serious question
a lot of these other things but that is
a reality
miles um threw winton off this
of the stage at a jazz festival because
he just hated this
little upstart but though miles
davis is one of the greatest musicians
ever
winton is probably the greatest
instrumentalist of the last 100
years discuss well there you go we're
finishing the interview on a very
divisive note
uh trevor phillips thank you so much for
coming on the show
and thank you all for watching at home
we will see you very soon with another
episode like this one
absolutely and they all go out 7pm uk
time take care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below